this guy thinks he knows how every
single woman thinks and what she does
and why she does it so if I dress nice
they think that I do it because I want
other men's attention that's not what I
want you don't know what I want you
don't know me most of my audience is
women I don't even post it for guys you
guys don't know you're trying for me I
posted before I leave yeah and I see
Olivia comment I'm like hell yeah it's a
gift it's just it's so upsetting to hear
them talk about women like some kind of
object like you guys don't know me and
thank God you don't I don't want
anything to do with you but you don't
know me you can't talk about the
scenario of me posting on Instagram or
me going out dressing nice and what it
means for Ethan like you guys don't know
what are you even talking about
what is this imaginary scenario yeah
that I'm going now to seek out attention
of other men and your attention can go
right into the trash can